iOS also has several other
run time security measures.
Address space layout randomization or
ASLR protects against exploitation
of memory corruption bugs.
With ASLR, when an app is run,
all memory regions are randomized.
Randomly arranging the memory addresses
of executable code system libraries,
stacks, and heaps, and
other related programming contracts,
reduces the likelihood of
many sophisticated exploits.
For example, an attempted Lib C
attack attempts to trick a device
into executing malicious code,
by manipulating memory addresses
of the stack and system libraries.
By randomizing the addresses of
these system libraries and stacks,
it will be hard for
such an attack to succeed, because
the addresses of these system libraries
and stacks are very hard to guess.